Okay, folks, time to get started.
Thank you for getting me your cases
back.
I think I had 31 submissions or 30
submissions by 9:45, which is when I had
to cut it off because I had to put the
numbers together for the
But yeah, obviously I didn't 10:30. So,
I hope you got it in before 10:30,
right?
And if you didn't and you're
right now trying to finish it up,
hopefully you'll get it done in the next
few minutes.
Before I start, how many of you drink
Celsius on a regular basis?
Okay.
And why do you like Celsius? You told me
already, but let's
I like the way it tastes. Okay. Um, I
feel like I'm not admitted like I don't
get a headache with other caffeine. So,
that's a side cost, but the side benefit
is you get more energy group of
So, it's like Red Bull without the Red
Bull, right?
I I I tasted one Celsius as part of the
research for the case. I didn't like it
that much. It made me a little edgy, but
that might be just me.
But I want to talk about the case, but I
want to talk about it not in terms of
this is the right answer. So, don't get
too focused if your answer is different.
I wanted to step back from the case and
think about the broader lessons that
will apply not just across corporate
finance, but across all evaluation.
So, first, if you notice when you when I
gave you the facts of the case,
everything is set in this discrete time
world. And we do this all the time in
finance. Year one, year two. When does
year one happen? At the end of the year.
And let reality is business goes on all
through the year. It's a convenience
assumption, right?
And in fact, there are some people who
argue you should use mid-year convention
because things are averaged out. I mean,
we can finesse this as much as you want,
but the truth is we take a world which
is continuous and we make this discrete
time assumption. Why does it matter?
Because there's a cash flow effect. If
something happens at the end of year
one, year two, year three, you're going
to build it in.
In the accounting world, you basically
also have these financial statements
that come out at regular intervals. So,
this is kind of a generic statement
about all discounted cash flow analysis
is time one, time two. And time zero is
not a year, it's a point in time. It's
today.
So, effectively, we're looking at should
we take this project today?
So, I'll give you my numbers and I said
don't freak out if your numbers were
different. I'll give you my rational.
I'll give you the distribution. You're
going to see a pretty you know,
widespread in numbers.
Based on my assessment,
the cost of equity for the Celsius Eats
project is about 9 and 1/2% and its cost
of capital is about 8.56%.
I notice notice I said Celsius Eats.
There is another set of cash flows on
which there might be a different cost of
capital you'd apply, the beverage
business.
But this is my cost of capital just for
the Celsius Eats project.
The return on capital I got, depending
on different assumptions, I got between
10 and 15%, but I could stretch it as
high as 25 or drop it down to five,
depending on what I included in invested
capital
and which after-tax operating income I
did.
My net present value was negative in the
finite life case.
-16 billion if I didn't count the
beverage benefits. If I counted the
beverage benefits, it became mildly
positive. Nothing to run excited down
the street about. It's a very, very
marginal project and the side benefits
are carrying it over the line.
And here's where I think the next
conclusion I got is the one that I think
we're going to disagree or be most in
most differential is when I extended the
life,
the NPV for this project actually stayed
negative.
And we'll talk about what because you're
saying, but I replaced my salvage value
with the terminal value. I want to talk
about the the trade-off there of
extending projects and why in this case
it's not making the net present value go
from negative to positive. But including
the beverage
benefits, NPV did get to be 329 million.
So, I have this mixed message, right?
Based on a standalone, just the effects
of the Eats it's tough to kind of
justify this project, but with the side
benefits, maybe.
I concluded that I would reject the
project. I'll talk about my rational
because you know, you've got a negative
NPV and I have a positive NPV. You're
saying it go either way. And I can see
the rational for both and I'm going to
push on if you accepted the project even
though one of your NPVs were negative,
I'm going to ask you what led you to
accept. And if you rejected the project
even though one of your NPVs were
positive, I want to know what it is
because I don't think there's an
absolute answer here. This is one of
those projects that's not an absolute
slam dunk in either direction. And I
designed it intentionally because if you
have slam dunk project, what's the point
of doing investment analysis, right?
You're just finessing the numbers.
So, let's start with the cost of capital
calculation. I computed two separate
cost of capital, one for the Eats the
food the snack food business and one for
the beverage business. And this is
because we've been and this is the point
we made over and over. The discount rate
for a project should reflect the risk of
the project, not the risk of the
company.
So, basically, I computed a cost of
capital for Celsius. Celsius has very
little debt. The the beverage business
has you know, I asked you to use the
beta. The beta that you get is 1.53 from
the regression. You feed it through. The
cost of capital you get for Celsius as a
company
is very high for two reasons. One is
it's a high beta and the second it uses
very little debt.
For the Eats business, the cost of
capital is much lower because the food
business, if you look at the pure group
companies that I gave you, had an
average at a median beta. I think it
should be 0.92, not 0.90. A median
regression beta of 0.92 and you work it
through and you clean up for debt and
you clean up for cash. The unlevered
beta that you get for just the food
business is 0.69.
Now, you can get variants of this
depending on whether you use the average
or the median, whether you use
aggregates, whether you computed the
unlevered beta for each company and
averaged it out. But clearly, the one
conclusion is the food business looks
like it's a much safer business than the
beverage business. The unlevered beta
delivers that message.
And I did say that this project was
going to be funded very differently from
the rest of the company.
It's going to use 20% debt, 80% equity.
So, you bring that in, that pushes the
cost of capital down for this business
to 8.56%.
9.53% cost of equity, 8.56% cost of
capital, but I have a much higher cost
of Why am I computing the cost of
capital for Celsius Beverages as well?
Because there's a segment of cash flows,
which is the beverage cash flows, I'm
going to discount them back at the at
the 13.69% cost of capital. I know some
of you looking at each other and say,
but we put it all into one cash flow and
use one discount rate. This is not
something I'm going to even take points
off, but something to remember when you
have two sets of cash flows that you can
have two different discount rates
playing on.
So, here's what you told me your cost of
capital was.
So, you can see the the average is nine,
the median is about 8.57%. So, there's
pretty close convergence. My guess when
you look at the high number, some of you
reported 10 or 11 is you were reporting
a weighted average of
the Celsius Foods and the Celsius
Beverage business,
right? So, if you had if you any of you
had the 11% plus, correct me if I'm
wrong because I haven't looked at your
full case and you know, obviously yet.
But it must be because you're using a
weighted average.
Anybody want to stand up for that
weighted average?
No? If you did?
No?
That's fine. You can use a weighted
average if you have a consolidated cash
flow. The only problem with using the
weighted average is the weights will
actually change as you go through the
project. So, it's messy to do. That's
why I'm keeping it as two separate cash
flows and discounting them each at a
different discount rate.
You guys look like you're shell-shocked.
Is it that the spring break is coming or
is this is a case that did this to you?
So, don't let the case do it to you.
It's not worth it, right?
So, here's my return on capital
calculation and this is the table I
spent the least time on.
Let me explain.
Ultimately, this case was about you
deciding whether you're going to invest
in this business or not, right?
So, how much time you spend on each
segment should depend on which decision
rule you're going to focus on. I made my
my judgment early on that even though I
was going to compute a return on capital
because accounting earnings matter that
my final decision
was going to be driven by cash flows net
present value.
So, decisions like should I allocate,
should I depreciate? I just made a
decision and moved on knowing that it
made a difference to my return on
capital,
but that it wasn't going to change my
decision.
It's something that I would like you to
think about as you think about any kind
of analysis where you spend your time
should be on those things that will
drive your decision.
And spending time on things that
required that are need to be reported,
but you're not going to base your
decision on, make an make an assumption
and move on.
So, here all I did was I took the
invested capital included working
capital in there and I divided by the
after the divided that number by the
after-tax operating income.
So, basically the return on capital
climbs over time and most of you found
this as well is as you get to your 13,
14, 15,
especially in the finite life case,
the return on capital climbs.
My return capital is actually much lower
in the longer life case and I'll talk
about what drives it lower.
Because it's the same you're saying it's
the same after-tax operating income, why
would the cash flows why the return
capital be lower? It's because I made
different assumptions about capital
expenditures in the longer life case
that makes my return on capital
different.
Bottom line is if I look at the return
capital 10.23%
is that a good return on capital? Well,
it's kind of messy, but if you compare
to the Celsius and this is the Celsius
Eats. If you just compare to the Celsius
Eats cost of capital, it is higher.
But given that some of the cash flow
earnings are coming from the riskier
business, the beverage business, now I'm
not sure I can even draw a conclusion
based on return on capital.
Any questions in accounting return
capital?
So, here's what you found and your
numbers were
hugely divergent.
The lowest number was minus 75.43%
and the highest number was 95%. I have a
feeling that those extremes are driven
by breaking some accounting rules along
the way. Okay? Those are numbers I can't
even get to in terms of the Something is
an intervening drive, but to the extent
that you may not making a decision on
this number, I'm not going to kill you
on some accounting judgment call, but
it's clearly something that is being
capitalized or not capitalized that's
driving this choice.
The median was about 9 and 1/2%.
Right?
Notice I report the average and the
median.
Why am I reporting both?
What's the What causes the two to
diverge?
It's asymmetric outliers, right? If you
have symmetric outliers, the average
aren't, but to the extent that you have
outliers, and this is something that I
think we talked about when we talked
about betas. The average beta can get
thrown off by outliers. The average The
more you have outliers, the more you
should be looking at medians rather than
averages.
So far, everyone with me?
Now, let's talk about the finite life.
15 years.
You're going to run your project as if
it's a 15-year project. This is not a
probabilistic event. You don't wake up
one day in year seven and say, "Oh, I'm
going to run this project for 15 years."
You make the choice up front. You run
the project as a finite life project.
First, any money you've already spent, I
don't care about.
At least in the context of deciding on
this project. If you ask me afterwards,
was this a good investment overall, then
I might bring it in, but to the extent
that I'm making a decision based on
forward-looking numbers, anything that
I've already spent, sunk costs don't
matter.
There is this logistics center side
effect, which is if I take this Celsius
Eats, I'm going to run out of capacity
earlier rather than later. Keyword is
earlier rather than later. Cuz even if I
don't take this investment, I'd have run
out of capacity, I think, in year 11.
I'd run out in year five. Think in terms
of incremental effect. The incremental
effect is not that you're building a
logistics center in year five, is you're
building it in year five instead of year
11.
In fact, you carry this through. There's
a second investment. I'll talk about why
I'm not including it. So, in my
analysis, I'm going to look at the
differential effect rather than just the
investment effect in year five. And I'll
flesh it out more in the next page.
Since I'm wrapping up this business
after 15 years, I'm not going to have
capital maintenance in year seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15
because what's the point? I'm going to
shut the project down. So, in this
scenario I'm not going to call it
scenario. In this version of the world
where I'm managing the project for 15
years, I'm going to essentially know
that I'm going to shut it down after 15
years.
I'm not upgrading my equipment and my
and my product line up in year 12 or 13
because it's all running down. You might
still have put some capital maintenance
and I'm perfectly okay with it, but I'm
going to treat this particular
investment very differently than the
longer life investment. Cuz I just don't
need to invest as much because I'm not
going to run the project after year 15.
At the end of year 15, what happens? I
shut the project down. And you can't
just throw the stuff out in the street,
right? You're going to try to get what
you can. And here I'm going to get book
value back. Book value back means that
you're not selling the inventory at full
price. You're selling it at cost. I'm
not make It's not a big It's not a
daring or aggressive assumption.
I get the book value back and it is
convenient to get book value back
because if you ignored working capital
and whatever the salvage values at the
end of 15 years, you have a loose end
you need to tie up for me.
Cuz you could make an assumption saying
none of this is going to be worth
anything. I can't push back on that, but
what's the loose end you then have to
tie up if your salvage value is zero if
you or ignoring it?
You write off something with book value,
you're going to get a tax savings.
So, if you're going to be consistent,
you have to show the tax savings you
will get at the end of year 15.
So, this basically is the wrapping up
and you can No, I want to focus in on
this logistics investment specifically.
What do you see at the top? And this
actually goes back. Remember I said ask
the question, what will happen if I take
the project, what will happen if I don't
take the project?
What will happen if I take the project?
I run out of capacity in year five. And
here you might argue my you have to make
the investment in year four instead of
year five. I'm going to act like I make
the investment in year five. I'll spend
225 million in year five. That's a 200
million growing at the inflation rate,
so basically the 225 million.
But that's if I take the project. If I
don't take the project, I'd have run out
of capacity anyway in year 11.
I'd have had to spend 276.6
million.
The effect of taking this project is the
difference in present value between
investing in year five versus year 11.
There are a couple of loose ends about
depreciation you will now get, so you
can put that in and there'll be
depreciation starting in year five. I
bring in the depreciation effect. That
depreciation effect is basically going
to be additional depreciation from years
five through 11 of 22.5. Why does it
matter? It gives you a tax benefit. But
starting in year 11, it turns negative
because I'd have made the other
investment with higher depreciation. So,
I'm just carrying this through to its
logical end game of if I invest, I have
to you know, spend my money earlier.
That's a time value effect. I'll get
depreciation earlier that'll get me more
tax benefits. The net effect of doing
this will be about 30 or 40
million.
Minus 30 or 40 million. Whereas if you
treat the entire amount
as an investment and you and you ignore
the year 11 savings, you'll be
penalizing the project for about 220
million.
As I said, there is if you if you pull
these things out, there's a second
investment you might have to make in
year 13. You're saying, "Why aren't Why
am I not putting it in?" What am I
planning to do in year 15?
Shut this project down, right?
And if you look at the collective
capacity that this project uses, it's
88%. It's 8% for each product. There are
11 products. It's 88%. It strikes me as
incredibly unfair to this project to
charge it twice, 200% capacity, when in
fact it uses only 88%.
Now, when you get to the perpetual life
case, we'll talk about maybe bringing in
this effect on a continuous basis, but
here I stopped with just this
assessment.
Any questions?
How many of you actually brought in the
year 11 number?
Okay.
As I said, this is not going to make or
break. You You brought the year 11
number? Or
Okay. And what was your thinking in? You
You did you do the timeline and
basically No.
Did you also bring the year 13 minus as
well?
No. There were some people that who did.
Clearly, that's not wrong, but then
you're going to leave this insane
capacity at the end of year 15. You got
to bring it into your salvage value. The
net effect of bringing in a year 13
number and salvaging it in year 15 would
be very small and that's the other
reason I did not do it.
So, here are my incremental cash flows
in the finite life case. I started with
the traditional accounting where I took
both the allocated G&A and the
incremental G&A, which makes no
intuitive sense, but I'm thinking like
an accountant. And then I fix it by
adding back that allocated G&A saying I
should never have allocated it.
So, there are my bottom line cash flows,
minus 250 million in year one.
Minus 7.2 million in year two.
Why is my working capital showing up in
year two my business is not starting
till year three?
Cuz the investments in working capital
have to be at the start of each year.
So, to get my revenues in year three,
I've got to invest at the start of year
three. And the start of year three is
the end of year two because in terms of
time, you're talking about January 1st
versus December 31st. So, my working
capital investments are going to be off
by a year if you made them in the same
year. And they will end in year 14.
And in year 15, I get the entire working
capital back. So, what's in my salvage
value includes all of this working
capital recovered. Plus the book value
of whatever I've left over because in
addition to the 250 million, I also have
each year 100 million at growing at the
inflation rate for the new products for
those
for those products from years three all
the way through year 11.
So, you you'd net out the cash flows.
You see you can see that
your cash flows are negative almost all
the way through your seven.
Because you're continuing to add
products. They turn positive and then
they ramp up pretty substantially.
So, in year year 15, I salvage the
project out of my incremental cash
flows.
I'm almost there.
Now, if you don't want to do that, you
know, because basically what do I do? I
subtract out the entire G&A, then I add
back the portion I should not which is a
messy process.
And I suggest just stay incremental.
I think this is a cleaner approach. You
get the same cash flows, but you don't
have that add back anymore because I did
not subtract in the first place. So, get
comfortable with both ways of doing
things. They give you the same answer,
but I think this approach gives you a
more direct answer.
So, I computed the NPV and I did break
it out into two parts. One was the cash
flows in the project which I discounted
back at the 8.56%
cost of capital. The other was the
beverage cash flows where I have the
revenues. And I did ask you to use the
operating margin that they already had
which requires you to go to the income
statement, divide the operating income.
It's a pretty healthy margin reflecting
that they have this brand name that
allows them to charge a higher price.
And you can see the net present value is
minus 16 million standing alone. It
becomes plus 185 million because the
beverage business cash flows tilted
towards positive.
I did compute the IRRs.
But to be honest, since I was not
planning to use the IRR, I didn't
finesse it very much.
But the IRR kind of gives you the same
answer, 8.31% IRR less than the cost of
capital, NPV negative. And if you
compute the IRR with the beverage cash
flows,
then you'd have to compare it to a
weighted average hurdle rate.
And it makes the the cut.
But as I said, my focus was on NPV.
Because I think this company should be
looking at NPV.
Let's talk about the finite life NPV you
found.
12 of the groups found a positive NPV,
17 found a negative NPV. So, clearly the
tilt was more negative than positive.
And many of you I think the reason you
got the negative was because you put the
minus 225 million in year five. So, if
you So, the only reason I might end up
with this mildly positive NPV is because
I might be you know, not counting as
much of a cost to that logistic center
as you are.
Yeah, the average NPV was actually
positive, 123 million. The median was
minus 21 million.
So, you already can see the tilt being
negative. The lowest NPV was minus 773
million. I haven't looked at the cash
flows or average. And the highest NPV
was 3.3 billion.
Right? So, I'll kind of let that
rest. Some
something is going on in the cash flows
that's pushing the NPV off that. But
basically, that's a finite life NPV
case. Any questions on the finite life
case?
So, let's talk about
the longer life. If you remember in the
case, I just said lengthen the life of
the project. I didn't say it had to be
forever, right?
So, you could have done extra 50. So, I
gave you that choice
because I wanted to see how much you
believed in mortality to begin with,
right? If you believe the world is going
to end in 50 years, you're not going to
lengthen things out forever.
And you say, "I'm I'll do 35 years."
Almost everybody used the perpetual life
case. I haven't looked in detail, but I
Did anybody use a
an extended life that was not forever?
Okay, but leave open that door, right?
This is not required. You don't have to
take every project and extend it
But here's what I did. I said, "Look, if
I'm going to run this project for a
longer life, I've got to start on day
one
running it very differently."
If you want to have If you want to be at
a healthy weight at the age of 65 and
have your blood sugar be good at the age
of 65,
when are you going to start on that
effort?
Not on the last day of your 64th year.
You've got to start today, right? So, in
a sense, you've got to behave very
differently with a different end game,
and that's what I'm doing.
So, what does it mean? Remember
depreciation gives me a cash inflow
in the project. And in the finite life
case, I collected and say, "Great, I'm
going to take the cash flow out."
Nothing wrong with it. It's perfectly
legal, perfectly appropriate. But if I'm
going to run the project forever, I've
got to keep everything in fighting
condition. So, starting in year one,
I basically or starting whichever year
my depreciation starts, I start with the
capital maintenance. So, capital
maintenance, I'm not increasing
capacity. I'm just making sure that my
my working assets basically are
preserved. So, if I'm spending money on
on building up a brand name, I'm
starting to spend even more because I
want this brand name to last forever.
So, the capital maintenance is set at
depreciation.
Depreciation being the logical thing to
connect it to because that's what the
accountant tells me my assets are
depleting in value.
And I reflect the the inflation. So, in
year three, I think my depreciation was
25 million. That's a 250 million. So, my
first product has not been invested in.
That year my capex capital maintenance
will be 25 million growing at the
inflation rate, 27.32 million. And I do
this every year the next 15 years.
So, when you look at my cash flows, they
now reflect a capital maintenance
expenditure that is tied to
depreciation. And in year 15, because I
tied to total depreciation, I'm in
effect setting aside money for a
continuous logistic center earlier
rather than later decision cuz I'm going
to be investing in a logistic center
five years earlier every single time
going through perpetuity.
So, to have an infinite life, I've
essentially built in capital
maintenance. The distribution system is
still You can see the cost in year five,
the savings in year 11. And those are my
cash flows to the firm
in the infinite life case.
Those cash flows, if we compare them to
my cash flows in my finite life, are
lower in every single year
except when I get to year 15.
What happens in year 15? In year 15, I
did assume a perpetuity. Why? Because I
was lazy.
Right?
If it's long The life is long enough,
perpetuity works. And I don't think I'm
going to get much give on my decision by
changing that. I computed the cash flow
in year 16. You always have to do that.
You cannot take your cash flow in year
15 and just put 1 + G on it.
Because things change in year 16. Right?
Your working capital is going to be
different because you have a different
growth rate. I did assume that my growth
rate, which is another thing I didn't
specify, would stay at the inflation
rate.
We'll talk more about what that
assumption buys me, but makes my life
easier.
So, I take my cash flows based upon my
after-tax operating income. So, you can
notice my capex
in my steady state is higher than my
depreciation. I want to keep the project
going. And I come up with 150 million as
my cash flow. You discount it You
discount that 150 million by the cost of
capital minus the growth rate. Your
terminal value for just the snack food
business cash flows is about 2,700
million. That's in year 10.
You discount it back. The present value
that you get is going to be based on
these cash flows. But as you can see,
here's the trade-off. And here's why
every company doesn't make every project
last forever. Because if we just did
what you know, if you just took the year
15 cash flows, replace salvage value
with terminal value, every project
should be required to run forever.
It's a It's a no-brainer.
But there is a trade-off here. To make
my project last longer, I've got to
sacrifice cash flows in the first 15
years. I've got to run the business
differently.
And that's good to bring that trade-off
to the table because sometimes a
trade-off will work in your favor,
sometimes it won't. So, as you can see
in every single year from year three to
to 15, my operating cash flows are lower
because of the capital maintenance. But
in year 15, I get this this boon of a
higher terminal value. And in this case
at least,
it actually makes my NPV more negative.
Okay? And
to be honest, that's exactly what I want
to see. If you take a bad project over a
15-year life,
you flip it to a perpetual project and
say it's become a good project. I should
be suspicious, right? How does a bad
project become a good project just
because you extend the life of.
In the case of the Disney theme park,
you could argue that the cash flow start
to build up over time, but that can't be
the case because here the cash flows
have already leveled out. You You're
really looking at just inflation growth.
So, my net present value from just the
Celsius business actually became
slightly more negative
when I brought in a terminal value
calculation.
But, what bailed me out here is the
beverage cash flows because they don't
have the same load continue to grow, and
that made the beverage part of the
business more valuable.
And the net present value went up, but
it's almost entirely coming from the
side benefits from the beverage
business.
So, this is kind of a general lesson I
hope you can take away is when you sit
here when you're doing evaluation
the assumptions you make about what
happens after year 10 animate what you
do for the next 10 years. So, it's not
that you stop in year 10 and say I'm
going to change growth rate. You got to
build the business differently with
that.
So, your findings on with the longer
life
every single group found a positive NPV.
Right? So, you'll extend the life,
right? Which I I'm not surprised by
because I you know, even for me there
was that tilt towards more positive.
The average NPV became 1.4 million. If
you remember, it was negative with the
finite life case. The median became 1.19
billion. The highest NPV become 4.4
billion, and the lowest NPV was 44
million.
And my guess is the lowest NPV there was
some cost you built built in
for the the longer life case that did
bring down the NPV.
29 groups when I did this the 30th group
hadn't come in yet. No. This Yes.
Right.
If you put in a growth rate higher than
the inflation rate
I would have come back to you and say
you need additional products. Where's
the extra investment? By keeping it at
the inflation rate, I was just living
off the past.
And the pushback you would give is
products run out of life. You got to
come up with new products. That may be
the investment you will need for a long
It actually makes it even worse for the
longer life case because now I've got to
come up with new products, spend another
100 million adjust for inflation to
replace old products. So, if you put in
a built in a finite life for for the
snack products
it'll actually make the longer life case
even worse.
And the message you're getting at
Celsius is the snack business is not a
great business for you to be in. That's
what I'm seeing in these numbers. It's
not a great business for you to be in.
And that was one of the reasons it
pushed me towards reject the project cuz
clearly I could come up with this with a
combination of assumption that gets me a
positive net present value.
But, I did not even want to open that
door because it just makes my net
present value in the in the longer life
case even more negative.
So, I did take your NPV finite and your
NPV longer life, and I looked at the
difference to see what lengthening the
life in my case it affected my NPV by
about what? 200 million, I think. It
increased my NPV.
And as you can see, there were you know,
a few of you who are on who are close to
my number in terms of the effect. It's
like three groups had change in NPV of
200 to 50 million.
But, a lot of groups the change in net
As I said, I haven't looked at the
numbers, but my guess is when I compare
your cash flows for your finite life
case and your cash flows for the
perpetual life case, I'm going to see
the same number for the next 15 years,
and in year 15 all that's going to be
different is salvage value versus
terminal value.
And that I would push back on because
that's not a mechanical error. It's not
an assumption error. And if your defense
is you didn't tell us anything about
capital maintenance.
I didn't want to, right? Because if I
impose that number, this is basically a
test of hey, when you lengthen life, do
you think And you think I don't know,
what do I base capital maintenance on?
Depreciation is a logical thing to
connect it to. It's a fact that you're
not told something. You don't the when
you you you're always making
assumptions, right? If you ignore
capital maintenance, are you making an
assumption? Yes. The assumption you're
making is you can length run this
project for as long as forever without
putting any money back
to preserve the assets.
You're always making assumptions. The
only question is do you want to make
them explicit?
You make them implicit. Again, I'm not
killing any
any group because you didn't do this,
but I wanted you to take this into
valuation because when you value
companies, this becomes a key component
of what drives value.
Because we think about it at the end of
year 15, you could have assumed project
ends in which case you do the salvage
value. You can assume the project ends
at a growth rate of 0%.
If you make a growth rate of 0%, you're
effectively assuming your project in
real terms shrinks over time, right?
Because there's inflation.
There you can set capital maintenance
equal to depreciation.
If your growth rate is
is set at the inflation rate, your
capital maintenance has to be higher
than depreciation, but just enough to
preserve your existing capacity.
And if you set a growth rate any number
greater than what my inflation rate I
think was 3%. You're using growth rates
of 4 or 5%.
I'm going to come back and say where are
the additional products that you're
investing in because then you're
assuming real growth, and real growth
requires more products.
And there I think you got to build in
that additional investment.
So, any questions on this because
to me this is one of the the key
questions in the case that kind of
extended to any kind of investment
analysis.
So, here's what you decided. Of the 30
groups, 17 said they would accept, and
12 said they would reject.
There's one group, and I don't mean to
pick on this group, that gave a
conditional acceptance.
Which is
if you believe if if you take the the
longer life, you should accept. If you
take This is not a probabilistic
statement. This is a choice you make as
a company. It's not that you get to end
of year 15 and you say there's an 80%
chance of this happening and a 20%
chance. If you eat whatever you want for
the next 30 years
and you don't take care of yourself
what you will look like at the end of
at the age 65 is not uh there's a
distribution. I'll tell you where you
fall. I know exactly where in the
distribution you're going to end up
falling. So, the choice you make up
front drives the NPV. So, in this case
you get different NPVs.
And if you as a company choose to accept
it
then you run the project as if it's a
longer life project. So, you can't make
a conditional statement because it's not
a probabilistic event where if a law
changes, it becomes a good net present
value. It's a choice you make up front.
So, if you believe in crowd wisdom, if
you had a Yelp for projects, right?
So, instead of doing your own analysis,
you're going to Yelp and say Yelp, tell
me what the NPV for the project and
hundreds of people are computing net
present values.
The crowd wisdom in this class is
that the finite life case
is not a very good project. It's a
negative NPV project. In the longer life
case, it's a much better project.
And the crowd wisdom is you should
invest, right? But, clearly there is
disagreement even among groups. So, I
want somebody
who accepted the project
even though their finite life
net present value is negative.
To be willing to stand behind the
decision and tell me what drove that
decision, right? Because clearly you
have different numbers presumably within
the group. Somebody said But, the NPV is
negative with the finite life case, but
the the consensus was
Anybody want to
tell me what
drove you to accept
even though your finite So, if you and
both your NPVs were positive, then you
know, you don't need to, right? It's a
slam dunk. But, if one of them was
negative and the other was positive.
What's your rationale for saying I'm
going to accept the project?
Anybody?
There are a lot of groups that did this,
right?
Of the 17, I think 15 had at least one
negative net present value.
So,
what's what's justification?
Yes.
I think the justification is that in the
context of Celsius, it's not likely that
they would actually be just selling
these new parts of the business after 15
years. In fact, it's going to be a
longer-term investment because the needs
of plastic and rubber are different.
Right. Longer business. So, leveraging
the terminal value approach gives a more
accurate way
And it's You also have a perspective in
the food business. Will people be eating
food 16 years from now?
Yeah, snack. So, the advantage being in
the food business, it's not like Zoom.
Where you come up with a new product,
and maybe there'll be a different
technology. You're still going to have
to open your mouth, stuff it with
something. And you're saying if I'm in
the food business, I this is So, part of
this is the kind of business you're in.
It's food business as opposed to, you
know, you know, it's computer chips or
new kinds of laptops. So, part of that
is playing in.
But, part of it is a perspective of the
world, right? You're probably more
upbeat set of people in terms of whether
the world will be around because whether
you like it or not, you know, you've
been you've been watching the COP 46 or
COP 47, and they keep telling us by 2050
Manhattan will be underwater. You're all
going to be like Mad Max survivors
roaming the earth hoping to survive.
Then obviously, you're going to be much
more pessimistic about forever.
You know what? I wager there are far
more people who reject this case now
than 30 or 50 or 80 years ago because as
you get more pessimistic about the world
lasting, it is going to whether you like
it or not, it's going to leak into the
forever decision, right?
Now, I want to take somebody on the
other side who said reject the project
even though their perpetual life
and PV was high.
Yes.
Caleb.
Right.
Value.
So, this is the flip side of the other
argument which is forever is a really
long time. I don't want to take a
project hoping that year 16, 17, 18, 19
carry me over the line, right?
My final question is does the fact that
this is Celsius
as opposed to Coca-Cola change your
decision?
Where is Celsius now? And if you put in
the corporate life cycle, where is
Celsius in the corporate life cycle?
It's probably still growth, young
growth, trying to break into a business
that historically has been really tough
to break into the beverage business,
right? They've succeeded. You got to
give them credit.
But this is a really tough business to
even hold on to.
Now, my reason for actually rejecting is
you got a lot on your plate, Celsius,
right now.
You've got this the main deal you made a
breakthrough into the beverage business,
but now, we've seen other companies,
Snapple, you know, breaking through and
then kind of leveling off. It's a
business where you're driven by fads.
Right now, people like Celsius, but it's
not an entrenched brand name yet.
Right?
You got enough on your plate that this
might be a distraction that takes you
away cuz if they're going to the food
business, even if the NPV is right about
the long-term value, my concern is that
might distract them from their core
business right now. The difference is
Coca-Cola is already established in the
beverage business.
They have less to defend.
So, if you're a young company looking at
a new business, I'm going to be more
cautious about that simply because even
existing business that's still not fully
established.
And you can already see how the same NPV
in five companies can lead to very
different decisions.
So, as I said, don't let what you've
seen in the slides kind of bring you
down because, you know, clearly I'm
going to be looking for, you know, there
there's a range of answers. Some are
more plausible than others. So, if
there's a math error on working capital,
like you subtracted the total working
capital instead of change in working
capital,
circle it and say this is, you know,
please don't do this anymore. It's like
a half a point somewhere. I mean, I want
to punish you once cuz I want you to
remember not to subtract our total
working capital from this day on.
On the maintenance uh the maintenance
CAPEX in the longer life case,
I think it's a more significant error.
So, I will actually send you a grading
template later today because I'll send
it before I send the cases. So, when I
grade your cases, I will actually list
the template actually list the different
things I was looking for. There are 10
things in this case.
And each of them has a code 9A, 9B, 9C.
So, the the grading template will give
you a grade and say this is what I found
on your case that cost you a half a
point or a point, right?
3A, 9B, you can go to the grading
template, look at what it is. And here
again, if I've missed something, maybe
there's a nuance there where you
actually dealt with 9B and I've not
caught it, let me know. I'll very
quickly fix it. So, you will the the
grading will be as transparent as I can
make it.
It's not for purple prose that I'm going
to give higher grades or lower grades.
Essentially, you've taken the numbers,
done the best you can, and made a
decision.
So, any questions in general about the
case? Jesus. Yeah.
One of these days is going to kill me.
But go ahead.
It's not even in theory, right? On day
one, if I make you the manager of the
project, I'm going to say run this
project for the long term because we're
not we're doing a 15-year analysis, but
we plan to be here for the long term.
The decisions you make
should be about this being part of our
long-term business. And my
the reason I put the numbers I did is
the way you will behave as a manager of
the business is going to be very
different knowing it's going to be a
long-term business than if I told you
it's going to be
you know, essentially shut down at the
end of 15 years.
There's only one company, right? So,
remember projects base So, what you're
doing here is looking at the effect of
Celsius EATS on Celsius the company.
It's all to the company. So, there is no
separate balance sheet and income
statement of Celsius EATS. It's part of
the That's why when you lose money in
year one or year two or year three, I
actually claim the tax savings right
away.
I know I looked at a couple of projects
and you were carrying the losses
forward. Again, that's technically you
can do it, but if you have a choice,
which you always do, you're going to
claim the tax savings right away because
why wait for 2 years if you do it? So,
it's all from the perspective of the
company.
So, when you talk about cost sharing,
there's only one company, there are cash
flows out and cash flows in. That's an
accounting judgment. It matters. Cost
sharing might mean an allocation, but
from an incremental cash flow
perspective,
it's always a company whose eyes I'm
looking at this through, right?
So, when you look at projects,
ultimately the money comes from the
company's shareholders. You're trying to
say does this make sense from an
incremental standpoint?
Any other questions?
Yes.
So, give me a rationale of So, on your
beverage cost of capital or cash flows,
give me your argument for using the food
business cost of capital.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a That's a great question. You're
saying why is the fact that this is a
new business that you've never done
before not leading to a higher cost of
capital?
I'll stay with you. What What is it
about the way we're computing cost of
capital that's making that risk
disappear?
No, but even step back. Why do we use
betas? It's because the investors in the
company are diversified.
And the argument is the risk you're
talking about are project-specific
risks. And if the
the company thinks about risk through
their perspective, I say this is company
money.
New projects are always going to be
riskier than old project because you
know less about them. There's more
estimation error in new businesses. But
if I am BlackRock and I looked at the
top 17 investors in Celsius, and they're
who's who of institutional investors, to
them, there are 100 companies like
Celsius entering new businesses but
which they don't know about. As long as
you make your
your estimate is not unbiased. You make
your best estimates of expected
revenues, expected cash flows, those
mistakes are going to average out.
It's a tough call to push this through
because managers want to use higher
discount rates for small for startup
projects because they think it's a
company's money being invested. It's
not. It's investors' money that the
company is a conduit to show through.
So, if this were a privately owned
company,
then I think your argument is I'm a
privately owned company. When I look at
a new business, I'm going to charge a
higher cost of capital because there the
total beta effect will kick in and
you'll see a much higher cost of capital
for that young project. So, it's really
that perspective of our risk that's
driving it for public companies that
allows you to use that cost of capital.
Okay. So, starting at about
I finished my last class at 4:45.
I have to put everything on 5:30. Your
cases will start to come back to you
around 6:00 or 6:30. They'll come first
in, first out.
So, whichever case came in first. And I
hope and I think most of you CC'd your
entire group. So, when I return the
case, I would return it to the entire
group so that one person doesn't then
have the responsibility of telling the
rest of the people what you got. So,
you'll get the graded case back. You'll
get my comments back.
And the PDF file, the comments will be
embedded in the file. The grade will be
on the first with that code of hey,
here's where you lost a point or a point
and a half or a half a point. You know,
it's a 10 10% of the grade case. So, the
worst that can happen,
I guess you could get every single one
of the 10 wrong, in which case you go
towards zero. I don't think anybody's
ever got a zero. No. So, you know, the
the one thing that I will mention about
the case as I looked at some of the
cases
is
I haven't checked for interest expenses
in your cash flows. I don't expect to
see them there if you're using a cost of
capital as your discount rate.
I was actually trying to make your life
easier by saying, you know, here's
company.
The minute you bring interest expenses
into your numbers, what are you doing?
You're making your cash flows into
equity cash flows, which opens an entire
can of worms, right? It's not just
interest expenses, you have to pay the
debt down. Your cost of equity then
becomes a discount rate. I'm perfectly
okay if you took that route, but you
better have gone all the way down on
that route because you subtract interest
expense, you come up with a cash flow.
You then have a cash flow to equity. If
you discount those back at the cost of
capital, you're mixing up apples and
oranges.
That's a consistency thing that'll
really get you into trouble.
So, let's put this away and I'm going to
kind of do the last few pages of this of
the first packet because we're very
close to the end.
And I want to talk today about project
options. So, let's step back, right? If
you think about how we analyze project,
we estimate the cash flows, we come up
with the discount rate, we take the NPV.
If the NPV is greater than zero, you
accept the project. If the NPV is less
than zero, you reject the project,
right?
That's static capital budgeting. Today,
all it an NPV tells you is should you
take the project today?
And the answer is yes or no.
But sometimes projects have what what I
what I would call options embedded in
them.
Let me explain.
Let's suppose you have a project which
has a negative net present value today,
but you have the rights to this project,
the exclusive rights to this project for
the next 10 years.
You have an option to delay, right? The
project is bad today, but it could
become positive 2 years from now, 5
years from now, 7 years from now. So,
we're going to talk about that option to
delay.
The second is a project might have a
negative net present value today, but it
might allow you to enter a market
that potentially could be a huge market.
So, when asked about Celsius, that was
one of the reasons I thought you might
take the project is not because the Eats
business itself is good, but the snack
food business is huge, and if they
succeed in this business more than they
thought they would, they'd be a huge
business they could enter into. It's
your option to expand.
And finally, one of the things you worry
about when you have a big capital
investment project, is you invest in the
project and then 5 years in you realize
you made a mistake.
It's nice to have the option to walk
away from your mistakes, both in
business and in life.
It's your option to abandon. The option
to delay, the option to expand, the
option to abandon. I'm actually not
going to put numbers in it, but I want
to actually
put the option in front, talk about the
implications.
You've all seen option payoff diagrams
in foundations, right? What options
share in common is you have limited
losses, potentially unlimited profits.
And that's significant. The fact that
you can't lose more than you invest in
an option changes the way you think
about risk with options. Why? Because
with risk you worry about downside risk,
I've limited that risk.
The option to delay is a very simple
option where you have the right to do
something. Today it's not viable.
But 2, 5, 7 years from now it can be
viable if you have the exclusive rights
to it.
What kind of investment do you have
exclusive rights to? What am I talking
about?
Maybe you have a patent or a license.
Right now it doesn't make sense for you
to use the patent to develop it.
But maybe in the next 14, 15, 16 years
of life the something can happen.
Can we value it? Yes, but it's very
noisy, very difficult to value. But the
implication of this is the right to do
something,
the license a patent, will increase the
greater the uncertainty of the business.
So, let's take an example.
Let's assume
that you're IBM. IBM is now a mature
company, it keeps struggling to find a
new way to grow. It has one of the I
think it might have the most patents of
any company on the face of the earth.
Many of them are useless, but let's say
one of those patents it developed 30
years ago or 25 years ago has a very
direct relevance for the AI business.
You got lucky, right?
You think AI was invented in November on
November 30th of 2022?
What happened on November 30th of 2022?
ChatGPT. But AI's been around. Vasant
Dhar, who teaches machine learning, you
might want to check his his um his
resume on the school site. He got his
PhD in 1984 from Carnegie Mellon.
Take a look at the title of his PhD. You
know what it was? Artificial
intelligence, 1984. It's been around a
long time. So, IBM's developed this
Right now that AI patent is not viable.
It's interesting, but it's not viable.
But you have 12 more years left in the
patent.
It's an incredibly valuable patent to
have, right? Why? This business could be
huge, and if something happens, clearly
something has to happen for this to be
valuable,
that patent could be worth an immense
amount of money. So, if you're a company
and you have exclusive rights or
license, for God's sakes, don't give
them away just because the NPV today
looks negative.
And I'll tell you a story to kind of
make that maybe maybe remember this
lesson.
In the early 1970s, RCA,
so US company,
had a big market share of the TV
business. They made TVs. You walked into
most American family households living
room, you'd have an RCA TV.
They came up with a new product, and
I'll describe the product, and some of
you might be too young to even recognize
the product. For a while it was in every
family's living room. They came up with
this appliance you could connect to your
TV
where you could put in a tape and
actually watch a movie.
It's the original VCR. And when they did
their initial net present value
analysis,
they came up with a big negative NPV.
Why?
Because what would you watch other than
the demo tape over and over again?
Remember this predated tapes being sold
in tape rental stores.
So, 1972 they concluded this is a
terrible
project.
And then they made their fatal mistake.
They said, "It doesn't make sense now.
The net present value is negative, so
it's worth nothing." So, they were
approached by Panasonic, Japanese
company, who said, "Look, we'll buy the
technology off you for a couple hundred
million." And you can see people at RCA
laughing behind their They know what net
present value we got. No, why would you
pay for this?
Panasonic, of course, buys the VCR
technology, and the rest, as they say,
is cultural and business history.
They take off, and of course, two
versions of tapes, VHS tapes, beta
tapes, Sony becomes and it becomes one
of the most sought-after add-ons to
every living room.
So, 1979 RCA decides it wants to make
VCRs again because everybody wants some.
Guess what it had to do? It had to go to
Panasonic, license the technology it
sold for 200 million, and pay more than
200 million every single year as a
licensing fee.
I'm not picking on Panasonic for not RCA
for not seeing what's coming. I'm
picking on them for giving away a
valuable technology based on a net
present value today.
So, if you have a right or a license,
it's not about what the NPV is today.
It's about how much uncertainty there is
in the business.
So, if you have a drug to treat
diabetes, it's not viable today. It
costs you 50,000 to make a single dose.
I understand the net present value is
going to be negative because no
insurance company will cover it.
But if I come to you and I'm Merck and I
say, "Can you sell me that drug?" You
got to factor in that you're in a
business with a lot of uncertainty about
how these drugs will evolve, and this
could become viable.
And if you're a company buying this drug
because on an option, remember it's an
out-of-the-money option, right? What
happens to most out-of-the-money
options?
They expire.
So, when companies buy portfolios of
patents, Google I think bought an entire
portfolio of patents from AT&T,
125 patents. It's not that they expect
every patent to pay off. All you need is
five of those patents to become
in-the-money patents, it'll pay for the
entire portfolio.
That's your option to delay.
The option to expand. You enter a
business
or a market which is a big market.
So, what would be a good example? Right
now it's AI.
10 years ago it might have been online
advertising. 20 years ago it was China.
It's a big market.
Let's say you do an NPV of the project
of entering this new market, and you
conclude that the NPV today is negative.
It's traditional capital budgeting, what
do I tell you to do? Don't enter the AI
market. Don't enter China. But here's
what you might be missing. If that first
investment gives you exclusivity on a
second investment to expand into the
market, you have an option to expand.
So, here the option is not the initial
investment. Think of that as a cost of
the option. The option is there's a
second investment you might make which
allows you to expand into a bigger
market. And because there's uncertainty
about how big the AI market would be,
how big online advertising would be, how
big China would be 20 years ago,
you're willing to take negative net
present value projects to be in that
market.
I'll wager there are people or companies
investing in India now which have
negative net present values on their
investments, but they're okay with it
because if the market gets to be as big
as people think it's going to be, then
you're going to be able to be in that
market. But the keyword here is
you have to have some exclusivity. I'll
give you an example to kind of
illustrate when you can use this
argument because this is at the essence
of when people say, "But there are
strategic reasons." What I hear is the
option to expand, right? Strategic
reasons come up if you have a big market
and it looks like the numbers are not
enough to get you over the line.
I want to take that strategic and put
some flesh on it. So, let's take an
example.
Let's assume that Marriott
let's take a potentially growing market,
let's say 20 years ago in China.
Marriott looks at China and says,
"We're going to open 10 hotels in China
in the big urban centers." They work
through the numbers.
They come up with a negative net present
value.
But somebody in the group says, "But
China is a big market."
Therefore, we should take this
investment with a negative net present
value
because there's this
this big market we can enter. That's an
argument you're going to hear about AI,
about India, there's a big market.
But there is a question we need to ask
to accept that argument, right?
What's the question you need to ask?
Marriott opens 10 hotels, negative net
present value, there's this potential
upside.
What When will you work on that upside?
If your 10 hotels do better than
expected, then you can say, "This is a
good market. I'm going to expand,"
right? Because right now it doesn't make
sense for you to open the extra hotels.
So, you watch your hotels really
carefully, they're delivering better
than expected numbers, and then what do
you get ready to do? Expand into the
rest of China.
But what's the weakest link here?
Are you the only one noticing that your
hotels are filled up?
Hilton has sent a spy
to stay at your hotels to see how many
rooms have filled up here.
And while you're watching, they're
watching, and just as you get ready to
expand, they do it, too.
That's the exclusivity problem. You
know, the title for my real options
paper that I wrote a long time ago is
opportunities are not options. Big
markets are not options. You got to give
me some degree of exclusivity.
So, let me modify the Marriott story.
Let's say the Chinese government invited
you in, and they also tell you that if
you will give you this exclusive right
open in this these parts of China
because you're making that upfront
investment. Then, you have some
exclusivity.
Don't let strategic or real option
arguments get by without pushing back
on, "Hey, what makes us special?"
And the the answer is, "We're the first
mover." That's the weakest form of
competitive advantage, right? I was
there first. You need something more
than that of saying, "Hey, I will have
an advantage because I've been there."
And finally, you have the option to
abandon.
It's an option we don't even think
about, right? In fact, in business,
you're encouraged not to think about
it because it's seen as a sign of
weakness that you're thinking about
failure and escape hatches even as you
look into project. The world we live in,
I think it's a sign of strength that you
think about, "What do I do if things
don't work out?" That's your option to
abandon.
What does it do? It essentially means
that if you have a project that's really
long term, it's more valuable on
long-term projects, and you come up
against this, "Hey, things are not
working out." Do you walk away from that
project? It makes you more likely to
take the project cuz it means there's a
downside protection you have of saying,
"I can walk away."
What are the implications for this? If
you take a long-term project, preserve
your option to escape. What What makes
that option go away? You enter into a
30-year
contract with your suppliers. You've
already locked yourself in, right?
You have long-term contracts with the
employees stretching over the next 30
years. You've locked yourself in.
So, while those might save you money and
give you higher cash flows, expected
cash flows, they also lock you in, take
away your option to about.
Life is full of options to delay,
to expand, and to abandon, right?
You're going out with somebody. Why are
you waiting to ask her or him whether
you want to get married? The option to
delay, it's nice to stretch this out,
right?
Eventually, you have to exercise
because there's an exercise date, so you
have to decide by then. You exercise.
You're now married.
Option to expand, I won't go on, but
Ashley Madison might help you, right?
And then, you have the option to
abandon.
Right? Life is full of options, and
people like to preserve their options,
but there's always a cost. That's
basically it, right? So, when you look
at a job,
embedded in every job offer are these
options, right?
So, when you think about taking a job,
you think about the option to delay
taking the job, the option to that that
that job will give you to enter into new
careers, new
and the option to abandon, the right to
walk away.
When I used to do the investment banking
training programs, so these were young
you know, undergraduates that joined in,
they're entering investment banks.
I don't know that the investment banks
knew it, but I used used to send a very
subversive message.
I said, "You're going to be asked to
work on big spreadsheets and do things
that basically taking up 18 hours of
your day 6 days a week." And those of
you worked investment banks know exactly
what I'm talking about.
My advice to them is preserve your
option to abandon.
What does that mean? That 11:00 your
managing director shows up. It's 11:00
on a Saturday night. Your managing
director shows up, puts a annual report
on your or the digital version of it on
your desk, and says, "I want this valued
first thing tomorrow morning." Why?
Sunday morning.
He's trying to figure out how much you
really want this job.
That's when the option to abandon should
kick in.
It's deeply satisfying while you
exercise it. It's taking the annual
report, throwing it back at your
managing director's face, saying, "Do it
yourself." That's a deeply satisfying
moment as it leaves your hand, and then
lots of bad things follow, right?
You know how you end up losing your
option to abandon?
My son moved into an $8,000 apartment
with three roommates. His option to
abandon is already starting to leave the
house.
He bought a big screen TV. He's got
subscriptions to expensive things. He's
Uber Plus. Hey, every time you build up
your expenses, your option to abandon is
essentially becoming weaker and weaker.
And in many ways, the people who have
the option to abandon are the most
valuable employees. You know why? Cuz
they can say what's on their mind. Cuz
what often ends up happening at banks
that are that creates a kind of fiascos
we often get up in is people know that
lending money to people who had defaults
in the past and acting as if they will
never default in the future. I mean, you
don't need a finance degree. You just
need common sense. You
But you're saying, "Why doesn't somebody
speak up?"
Cuz you lost the option to abandon. Now
you're afraid if you speak up, you will
be forced to abandon, and you can't
afford abandonment. So,
you might not need this advice, preserve
your option to abandon because it will
make you a much better person to have
around for a business. Make you a much
better banker, consultant, whatever you
choose to do.
But the bottom line is if you look at
this, flexibility does matter. Keep
preserving that flexibility. During
COVID, one of the things I looked at mid
midway through the years, I looked at
the damage across companies to see what
kinds of companies were damaged the most
by COVID.
It's no The answer might not surprise my
my I'm sure it will not surprise you. I
broke companies down based on how
flexible their cost structures were. And
I had to be a little creative in coming
up with this.
And when I looked across companies, you
could see that the companies that had
the least flexibility were affected the
most
by COVID or any crisis. I mean, if
you're an infrastructure company, what
are you going to do?
Right? You can't shut your hotels down.
You can't walk away. I mean, you can
shut your hotels down, but you can't
walk away from them. The more adaptable
And this is where I think Silicon Valley
has gained an advantage over their
status quo competition is an Uber is
always more flexible than a taxi cab
company.
Uber can walk away from a city.
Right? It will cost them a little, but
they're not wiping out entire assets.
So, flexibility matters, and I actually
broke companies down. I used to sales to
invested capital as kind of a rough
proxy for flexibility. Companies with a
high sales to invested capital are more
flexible than companies with a low one.
And you look And this was through
through
June 26th of 2020, the peak of COVID
kicking in. And you could see the
effects kind of vary based on where you
stood on this flexibility scale.
The last thing I want to talk about is a
question that was raised last last
session about, "Hey, what about existing
investments?" We've talked about how to
take new investments. And you already
have existing investments.
Now, what about them? Can you look at
those numbers and gain anything? There
are two reasons to look at them. One is
to do a postmortem.
Why? Cuz when you take a bad investment,
you got to figure out why did it become
bad?
It could have been pure luck.
It could have been a competitor, or it
could be because something in the way
you pick projects
is not working. So, it's a postmortem.
The other is to make decisions about
what to do about those existing
investments. You're saying, "What do you
mean what to do?" Remember, you have the
choice of shutting that existing
investment down,
keeping it going, or even adding more
money and making it work better,
So, let's look at what you do when
you're looking backwards as opposed to
forwards. So, So say you have a 10-year
project, and it's 2-years into the
project. The pro- You've already taken
the project. It's 2-years into the
project. The actual numbers have come in
for those 2-years.
You compare them to the forecast
numbers. The actual numbers can be
higher than your forecast, above the
forecast, or lower than the forecast.
They'll never be equal to your forecast.
Take that off the table because that'll
never happen.
Now, which of these outcomes makes you
happy? When the actual numbers to come
in above your forecast or below your
forecast? You want them above your
forecast.
And if it's above your forecast, you
say, "This is great. We took the right
project." But they could be below. So if
they're below your forecast, the
question you're asking is, "Will we
somehow recover to our forecast, or is
this project going to be a much worse
project than we thought it was when we
took it?"
And I'll give you the choices you face,
right? If you look at these the actual
numbers coming in below or above the
forecast
it could be either because of luck,
things you don't control, right? COVID
happening in 2020. Or it could be
because of bias.
How can you tell the difference? Let's
say you have 100 projects you've taken
in the past, and each one of them you
compare actuals
to what you forecast.
Even every single one of the actual
numbers come in below your forecast,
don't tell talk to me about chance and
luck.
Clearly, there's some bias in this
process. You're systematically
overestimating cash flows.
If it's pure luck, you should get not a
50/50, a roughly 50/50, where half of
your projects come in below expectations
and half come out.
I seldom look back at my valuation, but
one thing I do every decade or so, I
look at the 200 companies I've valued
over the previous decade. I look at my
predicted numbers for Airbnb in 2019,
look at the actual numbers
to see if I'm coming in below. And it's
purely for feedback because if I
consistently find myself with forecasted
numbers
that are above the actual numbers.
There's a message there saying, "There's
something you're doing in your
valuations that's leading you to be
biased upwards." And if I'm listening,
I'll have to change the way I think
about value.
So there's feedback here. It's not
because you're beating yourself up for
being wrong.
But if you're biased, then there's
something you need to fix.
So forget about the equations. They
sound messy. But there are four choices
you have with an existing project. The
first is at the end of year two, you
look at the numbers and say, "These are
awful.
I'm going to shut the project down.
Liquidate the project. Get whatever you
can on eBay." Second, you know,
if the
So if the net So that's if the cash
flows are so negative, there's no If the
cash flows are positive
but they're less than what you can get
by divesting the assets, less than the
salvage value
you basically terminate the project,
collect the salvage value, you get a
higher cash flow.
The third is if there's somebody outside
who's willing to pay more than the next
8-years of cash flows. For whatever
reason, they get synergies, they like
your project, they have a rosy view
then you should divest the project.
But if the cash flows you get are
greater than what you can get from that
divestiture, you should actually
continue your project.
Now, earlier in the class we talked
about companies being in bad businesses,
why do they stay in? The answer is that
what you get as a continuing business is
actually greater than what you can get
from somebody buying your airline from
you because you already know it's a bad
business.
So I'm going to take a very simple
example to kind of end this this entire
section.
We I've talked about Disney all the way
through, and as you know, I'm you know,
I go to Disney all the time. And when I
first started going to Disney, there was
only one theme park in Anaheim,
Disneyland.
The original Disneyland.
About maybe 30-years ago, 25-years ago
Disney bought it built a second theme
park right across the walkway from
Disneyland called California Adventure.
And the original idea was that you would
draw people from who came to Disneyland
to California Adventure.
And their original estimate that about
was that about 60% of the people going
to Disneyland would come to California
Adventure. Why only 60%? Because the
original idea of California Adventure
was more like an amusement park with
lots of rides.
It was supposed to be a vision of
California with the big sun in the mid-
So people with older kids would come
across, people with younger kids would
only visit Disneyland.
That was the original idea. They built
the theme park and spent a lot of money
on it.
Okay.
So they were expecting about 100 million
in cash flows, after-tax cash flows from
the California Adventure theme park.
But years into it, by 2008, when they
looked at the actual numbers, it looked
like only about 40% of people were
making it across. And that the cash
flows where they were collecting was
about 50 million, well below the 100
million that they thought.
And they faced a choice, which is, "What
do we do about California Adventure?"
And here are the choices they faced.
They could shut it down.
It used to be parking lots before.
And return it to parking lots. That's
one choice. The second is
they can continue with the status quo.
50 million is not you know, not a bad
cash flow. You can It's less than what
they thought they would make, less than
what the net present value would have
been, you know, to make the net present
value. But it's too late to get that
money back. And the third is to actually
invest another 600 million to make
California Adventure more attractive.
What What would that do? It maybe would
increase from 40 to 60% and increase the
cash flows from 50 to 80 million. So you
have three choices. You can liquidate
the theme park, collect whatever you get
as salvage, convert to parking lots.
The second is you can continue to do
what you're doing, and the third is to
invest. You know what Disney decided to
do?
They decided to invest. They actually
built cars, and then they built a Star
Wars. So basically, they've spent a lot
They've actually spent far more money
investing in California Adventure than
they did in Disneyland.
And let's work through the numbers. If
you look at the value as a continuing
business
you get 50 million a year every year in
perpetuity, the present value is 1.1
billion. So as a continuing business,
you get 1.1 billion. If they go out and
invest, uh you know
let's say the abandonment value, if you
liquidate is half a billion.
Well below already the choice, right?
Continue over abandonment. But if they
invest an extra 600 million, they can
increase their cash flows
by 30 million a year.
The present value of the increase is 662
million. You're investing 600 million,
that's a net present value of 62
million.
There will be times where you put money
into a bad business
not because you're happy about what it's
doing, but you're saying that
incremental investment is going to make
a difference.
To be honest, I don't think Disney's
making its money back on California
Adventure, but they're too deep in the
hole right now.
They keep throwing more money into
California saying, "One This change will
make it happen." You know?
And they keep raising ticket prices, and
of course this is going to have this
ripple effect. It's changing the mixes,
I said, to more adult people now coming.
So there are all these ripple effects,
and I'm not sure looking back
that they feel they did the right they
did the right thing. But every company,
in a sense, has to think about existing
projects and start asking these
questions.
Yes.
You said a little bit earlier about how
it's kind of seen as a bad business to
abandon projects.
Because of that, you see that even if
abandoning is the right decision, that
it doesn't happen as often as it should.
Especially when the original person who
accepted it is still at the top of the
decision-making chain, right?
I have zero hope that the Yankees will
get rid of some of the because as long
as Brian Cashman is there
the contracts he signed are his
contracts.
Abandoning it will be an acceptance.
See, this is the reason we you know,
investing, there is this finding that
people don't sell losers
early enough. They hold on to losers too
long.
Why? Cuz the act of selling is telling
the world, "I screwed up."
So what do you do? You cover your eyes
when you look at your portfolio. You
say, "I don't see the loser. I don't
remember investing in Tesla at 400. I
don't even see Tesla in my portfolio."
So there is this thing of abandonment is
an acceptance, "Hey, I made a mistake."
And it's much more difficult for the
person who made the original decision to
do it. So you know when abandonment
happens? When a new CEO comes in, when
new top management comes in. Cuz they
have absolutely no qualms about
admitting to the previous guys'
mistakes.
Why? Because they want to make their own
mistakes starting today, I guess. So
they will sign their own bad contracts,
which they will own. But it is part of
that that psychological It's behavioral
finance kicking in, and capital
budgeting is full of behavioral
components, right? Why do we
overestimate cash flows on projects?
Because acceptance seems like such a
I mean
those groups that accepted felt a little
easier on it on a cycle. It's difficult
to say no. It's difficult to reject
because you seem like you're on the
wrong side of that optimism-pessimism
divide, right? And I can rule it out and
say you shouldn't have that, but it is
behavioral. It is It'll mean that more
projects more bad projects will get
accepted
than good projects being rejected. It's
the nature of this game. Which is why
when you look back at companies and you
look at their actual returns on capital
they never measure up to what you
thought they would look like if you
looked at the original project analysis,
So abandonment is tough to do. You know,
walking walking away from a decision you
know you made.
Okay?
So one of the reasons I gave you that
sunk cost exercise with your MBAs at the
start of the very last semester of your
MBA, and you look back and say
"Oh my god, what was I thinking?
There is the sunk cost phenomenon.
You're already a year and a half into
this.
And you can let that kind of feed into
whether you walk away, even though it
might make complete financial sense.
It's tough to say I spent a year and a
half doing something I shouldn't have,
and I chose to. Yeah.
Yep.
I'll tell you in companies abandon, it's
usually because they get external
pressure from venture capitalists or
leading. It's not managers always will
have a tough time abandoning because
this is their baby. These are their
projects. So, I think it's not a
question of where in the life cycle
you're in, it's how much external
pressure you feel.
Right? In fact, what was Elliott's big
thing with Disney? He wanted Disney to
abandon some of its businesses. And
Disney said, "No, no, no, this is what
Walt Disney left to us. We can't walk
away from it."
But activist investors, external
investors are usually the kind of prod
that makes you look at existing
investments saying, "Maybe we shouldn't
do this anymore."
So, it took us a while. So, let me read
the original We're one box into six
boxes. You're saying, "We're 15 sessions
into the class. How the heck are we
going to do it?" We've laid the
foundation. What we're going to do from
now on is going to build on what we
learned. The hurdle rate
for an investment should reflect the
risk
in that investment. And by now we ask
you, "How do you measure risk?"
We have an answer, right? It's an answer
that requires assumptions. We measure
risk for equity investors through the
eyes of the marginal investors in the
business.
Which if they're diversified will give
you a beta and a cost of equity. If
they're not, will give you a much higher
cost of equity. We measured the cost of
debt through the default spread, the
risk in that.
And should reflect the mix of debt and
equity. That's what the weights in the
cost of capital do.
We have
completion, closure on the hurdle rate.
And it's a starting point for corporate
finance because it kind of gives you all
how your decisions play out in risk and
return. So, next session when we start
after the break, we will start with
packet two. So, if you haven't
downloaded it, please do so.
Because we're done with packet one. And
the quiz will cover Okay, the quiz will
cover everything through this page. So,
I'm not going to do capital structure in
the quiz. It's all about investment
analysis, what you did on the case.
So, go back and review the case and you
know, push back on me if you don't agree
with something I've done because it
might be part of your quiz in a
different version.
Yep.